in this
lecture i will introduce the use of
hyperbolic graphing bodies
in learning representations for graphs
that exhibit
certain hierarchical and tree-like
structure
so in previous lecture we have focused
on graph representation learning in the
euclidean space
which is the r to the n however
euclidean in bodies cannot always
capture
complex graph structure so here we have
an example of a tree structure
a complete binary tree where the first
level we observe there
there's one node and the second level we
have two nodes and the third level we
have
four nodes etc so in this kind of
tree-like structure
often there there is an exponential
increase in the number of nodes
as the depth of the tree increases so
these kind of trees are difficult to be
embedded in the euclidean space
as you have seen because the slide
itself is a 2d plane
and we can see that as the depth
increases
the nodes that are leaves become closer
and closer to each other
to the point that they can no longer the
impending space could no longer
represent
the distance between them faithfully
because they are very very clustered
together due to the exponential increase
in the number of nodes
so here we are focusing on these kind of
graphs with
such tree-like structure so we define
these kind of tree-like graphs
as graphs that are similar to the tree
for example the binary tree
as shown above but it can still contain
a very few cycles
for example in real life situations we
can have things like
knowledge graph that are organized
hierarchically because
many of the human knowledge are
organized hierarchically
and at the same time there could still
exist a certain
kind of loops in in this structure so
it's
most mostly a tree but with a certain
number of
loops in in the graph itself
so here we're considering this kind of
structure and
we want to note that embedding geometry
has been very important
in terms of capturing this kind of
special graph structure
here we consider some other interesting
graph structure
for example if we have a graph with a
very
many very large cycles these kind of
graphs are best embedded into spherical
geometry
because in a spherical geometry with a
positive curvature the
um the graphs uh we can naturally embed
many many cycles because the sphere
contains many many cycles um whereas
if you if we have a grid like graph a
euclidean space is the best
because as you can see the cartesian
coordinate itself
is a grid like structure so a ukrainian
space with zero
curvature would be the best so how about
hierarchical and
tree-like graphs for these kind of
graphs we're considering the use of
hyperbolic space
which is an alternative embedding space
to model
embeddings for trees with tree-like
structure
the advantage of hyperbolic e-body space
allows it to naturally model trees and
we will
elaborate on these advantages in the
later
later slides where we explain the
definition
however there are certain challenges
when we combine deep learning and
hyperbolic spaces
the primary reason is that existing deep
learning toolboxes
can only be applied to a euclidean space
whereas in hyperbolic space we need to
define special operators
to to perform these kind of deep
learning operations
um let's first define what is a
hyperbolic space
so hyperbolic geometry differs from
euclidean
geometry by its fifth axiom of
euclidean geometry which is the parallel
postulate
so in euclidean geometry the parallel
possibilities is that in a given plane
given a line and a point that is not on
the line itself
at most one line parallel to the given
line can be drawn through the point
um and this this seems very obvious in
the euclidean space if we have uh if
if we have a line then the line parallel
to itself is
kind of unique uh if we only consider
lines that pass through one point
however in hyperbolic geometry there are
infinite number of lines that are
parallel to a given line through the
point
this might not seem very intuitive
because we
are very familiar with euclidean space
but here is a representation of a
hyperbolic space in terms of conquer
above
so we will explain what is pointing
about layer but it's basically a way to
visualize the hyperbolic space in
euclidean space
and you can see the blue line here um it
looks like a curve
but it is actually a straight line uh in
in the hyperbolic space and we can we
can also
define a red point here which is another
point that is not on online
um in hyperbolic geometry states that uh
there are infinite number of lines that
are parallel to the line
and these lines are actually drawn in
the visualization so all these
uh curved uh black lines that we draw
here
they're actual actually straight lines
in
hyperbolic geometry and they also pass
through the red point
and at the same time they are also
parallel to the blue curve
sorry into to the blue straight line in
the hyperbolic space
and that's mainly how it differs from
the ukulele space
so because of this spectral uh
properties
hyperbolic space cannot be naturally
represented in the euclidean space
because it violates the fifth uh the
fifth axiom of nuclear space which is
the parallel
posturing so we commonly use two
geometry models to represent or to
visualize hyperbolic space
by embedding it as a subspace of the
euclidean space
and they are also equivalent so we can
also map
between these two models that visualize
hyperbolic space in euclidean space
so the first model that we're going to
introduce is the poincare model
this is a model um where we represent um
we represent the hyperbolic space as a
open and open ball
so a visualization of it is on the right
where we can see a ball um and
this by open we mean that the set of all
points
in this hyperbolic space uh do not do
not include the boundary of the ball
so the the outer circle uh is not part
of the
ball but everything inside the circle is
part of the
parkour concrete bar and the radius is
proportional to the square root of k
and we will introduce what is k layer k
is actually the inverse of the curvature
and and the important property here is
that each triangle in the figure has the
same
area so it might not uh again it's not
very intuitive in euclidean space
uh as we see like all the triangles in
the middle tend to have a larger
uh seems to have a larger area in the
euclidean definition of
euclidean metric but
but every triangle here actually has the
same area
and you can see why this space is very
amenable to embedded
hierarchical or tree-like structure
because you notice that
in the middle or in the center of the
pancreas ball there are very few of
these triangles that are
in hyperbolic space whereas towards the
edge
of the of the circle
you can see like there are exponentially
many of these
small triangles uh albeit with the same
area that are embedded uh towards the
edge of the
hyperbolic space or the two towards the
edge of the punctured ball
so this exponential increase in in terms
of the
area or the volume um as the
radius or the norm increases allow us to
embed hyperbolic trees so basically
trees
can be embedded by embedding its root
in the center because there are very few
of them
and embedding all the leaves on the edge
of the concrete ball
because there are exponentially many of
these leaves
at the as the depth increases
um and we're going to introduce another
alternative model
that models the hyperbolic space which
is called the
hyperbolic model and also called lorenz
model
this is basically an upper sheet of a
two-sheet hyperbolic and that is
visualized in the figure below
and this is also a set of euclidean
space so
um unlike the pawn career model as you
can see there are exponentially many
um triangles towards the edge of the um
concrete concrete ball um here hyper
blowing model is numerically more stable
meaning that you don't have to have
extremely high machine precision to
represent all these
uh small triangles in terms of their
embeddings
uh towards the edge of the concrete ball
here
it is basically in the hyperbolic and
there is no upper bound so it can
go um the numbers can grow very large
but
it does not require very high number of
floating point positions to represent
the exponentially many
points in that that are towards the edge
of the pancreatic bar
so papers have shown that hyperbolic
model is numerically more stable
and um it also have the advantage of
having
a slightly simpler formula to represent
its
metric and uh as well as uh distances
in um in in this hyperbolic model so a
lot of times
we do derivation and we represent the
uh um neural network architecture inside
this hyperboloid model
so these two are um so the poincare
above and the hyperblood model these two
are equivalent in the sense that we can
have a mapping
uh that uh that are between the punctual
ball and
the hypobloid and this mapping is one to
one so
it's a bijection um
so so given us the brief introduction of
the
hyperbroad bullet space we want to also
define our task here
so the task is the typical graph
representation learning
which we have um learned throughout this
lecture
and tasks could be things like link
prediction
or node classification and an example
um um example embedding space that
achieves this
kind of task is the poncare inverting
by nico in 2018. so
in this visualization which is in the
form of a poincare ball
we can see that entities are embedded
inside this
puncher ball and towards the center of
it
is um um they contain the nodes with
very high hierarchy or
nodes that are towards the roots of the
tree
so for example entities we have a
physical entity
we have abstraction or organ
organism these are all very abstract and
high level nodes that can contain
many many different trojans and and
towards the edge of the
uh embedded space there are many many
different
exponentially many entities can be
embedded there
and these are typically nodes that are
in the lower hierarchy or towards the
leaves
of the tree like graphs for example
things like
arrival metabolic rates these are very
concrete and
very detailed
description of certain entity and there
are exponentially
many of them which can be embedded
towards the edge of the concrete ball
and this is basically the kind of
embedding we want to achieve
so that we can perform things like link
prediction which means we can predict
whether an entity and another entity
in this in this knowledge graph are
connected
meaning that for for example whether
the bread and food are connected it
could be connected through a
hierarchical relation
or it could be connected through a
non-hierarchical relation
so this is link prediction and we can
also perform node classification
by predicting a label for each of these
nodes in the graph
okay and before going into uh the
detailed architecture
let's first also
look into how hyperbolic space are
mathematically represented
so formal definition of the hyperbolic
geometry
is a manifold which is
which is basically a high dimensional
surface a 2d
surface in but in high dimensional and
a remaining manifold is a special
manifold
which is equipped with two things one is
the inner product
so the inner products between two points
have to be defined and it is
it will define a metric space or like
how distances are computed
in this remaining manifold and the other
thing that
is that is necessary for remaining
manifold is the tangent space
um which is a euclidean space that
approximates the manifold
but only locally so you can imagine it
is a tangent to the surface
at a certain point touching the surface
at a certain point x
both function has to remain in manifold
states that both functions
which is the inner product and the
tangent space has to vary smoothly
or called differentiable on manifold
there are also other concepts that are
uh needed so here
we also consider the geodesics geodesics
is defined as the shortest path in the
manifold
which is analogous to the straight line
in rn so if you remember the
the plot where we have the parallel
postulate
um in hyperbolic space um all these
curves are actually geodesics so they
are the shortest path
between two points in the inner manifold
and that's why
we can say that there are infinitely
many straight lines passing through the
point
um that are parallel to a given line
um the hyperbolic space is a romanian
manifold
with a constant negative curvature here
we represented
as negative one over k where k has to be
greater than
zero so as you can see when k becomes
very very large
the hyperbolic space curvature becomes
very very close to zero
um and zero just means a flat space so
it will become more and more euclidean
as the sk increases but
the more negative is the curvature so
when k is small
the more curved the space will be and um
here we look at a little bit of how does
the curvature affect the
affect the embedding space
um so we use our negative one one
over k to denote the curvature and uh
root k is also the radius of the
poincare ball um
and that's how the radius is related to
the curvature
so um um yeah
if we look at the hyperbolic model um
the the formula is actually very simple
so this is the
inner product definition which is also
called the minkowski inner product
in hyperbolic space um so if we have a d
dimensional hyperbolic space
the hyperbolic model um will have a d
plus one dimension
and the um the inner product is defined
um
by these two things so um there is the
negative part of the inner product
and there is also the positive part of
the inner product which behaves
almost identical to the euclidean
component
but we also have the negative part which
is
which has a negative sign in this inner
product
and based on this inner product
definition the
distance between two hyperbolic points
can be computed
as such so given two points x and y in
the hyperbolic space
um you we can compute this minkowski
inner product
and divide by k which is related to the
curvature and
the archage means the the inverse
of the hyperbolic cosine function so we
use this function
to compute the distance between two
points
and another important concept is called
the tangent space
so as we mentioned that tangent space is
basically a euclidean
um euclidean approximation
on a local point of the manifold so a
local neighborhood of the manifold
we can have a euclidean space that is
tangent to the manifold
but only touching the manifold at this
one point
so for example in this visualization we
have this hyperbloid model again
representing hyperbolic space and
the the tangent space at the north pole
which is the bottom of the
hypobloid is drawn over here
and we can define certain mapping here
so this
um this line um this is actually a
straight line
of course it looks like a curve in
hyperbolic space but if we also map it
to the tangent space
this becomes a straight line because the
tangent space is the euclidean space
and the tangent space is defined again
through this minkowski inner product
um where if we do inner product between
v
and x it is zero so that is the
that is the that defines the the set of
all points
um v such that the inner product between
v and x equals to zero defines the
entire
um tangent space at the point x
um and finally we um we discussed a
little bit about
geodesic distances um geodesic distance
as we mentioned is analogous to the
shortest path in the euclidean space
and it's also the concept of straight
line in the hyperbolic space
and the more negative the curvature uh
the more the geodesics will bend inwards
towards the center
so and and the distance between two
points will also increase
so here is an example plot where we
compute distance between
two points x and y with the same
coordinates
so um like imagine something like x is
0.5 0.6
y 0.2 or 0.3 and the distance between
them
actually increases if the curvature
increases uh
sorry if if the curvature becomes more
negative so
um towards the more active parts the the
distance between them actually
increases more so it can be more
visualized in
in this figure where um we have this
two points here x and y in the
hyperbolic space here we just
represented in the
parker ball and here uh zero is the
origin
um root k is the is the
radius which is also inversely
proportional to the curvature of the
space
and the dark blue um curve means um is
the boundary of the
hyperbolic space where um the curvature
is more negative right the more negative
the curvature is
the the smaller the radius will be so
uh you can see that the geodesics are
also drawn here
so um if the uh in the dark blue so in
higher
higher curvature space the the geodesics
is more bent towards the center
towards uh the center of the hydraulic
space
uh whereas uh for the lighter blue
version or the lighter blue space which
has larger curvature
the uh geodesic is less bent inward
and um in the extreme case where the
um xy uh the space is euclidean meaning
that the poincare ball is
kind of infinitely large then the
geodesics
does not bend at all which recovers our
euclidean concept of shortest path which
is
basically a straight line here
and another important concept based on
all these definitions is the exponential
and logarithmic map
so this is a map that we can map from
the tangent space
to the manifold and vice versa so the
exponential map maps
points any point in the tangent space to
the euclid um
from the tender space to the euclid from
the euclidean tendon space to the
hyperbolic
body manifolds and the logarithmic maps
from the manifold back to the euclidean
tangent space
so here it is a visualization and we use
the norm um
to represent the inner product between
two points
using this special uh minkowski inner
product definition
so we can conceptually um visualize it
as
you know we have a v in the tangent
space of x
and if we were to map it back to the
hyperbolic space
it becomes the point y which is on the
uh and inversely we can use logarithmic
map to map from this y
the blue point back to the red point v
which is in the euclidean space
is a euclidean coordinate in the tangent
space of x
so here this notation we use x here
as the the point that is touching so the
tangent space of
x is the is the euclidean space that we
want to map
to and from and k is the curvature uh so
it is the
the inverse of the curvature that we
have defined
and here notice that we have to use this
kosh and
singe function which are the uh which
are the hyperbolic
trigonometry here um the formulas are
really very complicated
um but if the high-level concept is that
there exists
you just need to know that there exists
such mapping between the
the tangent space as well as the
manifolds
and we can use such mapping to
perform operation in the euclidean space
and map it back to the hyperbolic space
so given all these preliminaries we can
now introduce the
hyperbolic gnn so the main challenge
that we are focusing on here
is that input features are usually
euclidean
but we want to map it on to the
hyperbolic space to
to compute the node embedding on
hyperbolic space and the second
challenge is that
we need to perform aggregation in the
hyperbolic space
so that we can perform message passing
and the third challenge is that
hyper we do not know what is the right
amount of curvature
for the hyperbolic space that can
perfectly impact the graph
so this is also something that we need
to learn in the meantime
um so if you recall the um the um
gnn formulation is mostly very similar
so
here is an outline of the gnn
architecture
where we first compute the messages
between all the neighbors as well as the
center nodes
and and then we aggregate all your
neighbors messages
to compute to compute a representation
the hidden representation after the
aggregation and finally
we will make an update of the
representation
so that the the next level
representation will
will capture the information of the
previous layer
representation so this is this will be
the
typical like message allocation and
update function
but in hyperbolic space so notice that
here we are writing
um some superscripts for example like k
l minus one so this will indicate the
curvature or the inverse of curvature
at the layer l minus one and here it is
k
l minus one k l meaning that the update
function needs to convert
the point from the uh hyperbolic space
of the previous layer
so in the layer l minus one to the
hyperbolic space
of layer l
and the high level concept is also
visualized in the
um in the figure here so we have a bunch
of points
which are the previous layer embedding
of the graph in the previous hyperbolic
space
and we perform a message computation of
these
between these points as well as this
center point here
and after we perform these messages we
need to aggregate all these messages and
we perform this aggregation in this
tangent space of the hyperbolic space
because there is no natural definition
of neural network operations
in the hyperbolic space but if we map
them into the tangent space then we can
do something like a center of gravity
inside this tangent space
at the point x so we perform this
aggregation
in the tangent space and after the
aggregation we have the green point here
which is then maps back to the um
another hyperbolic space of a different
curvature so you notice that here
it is the layer l minus one sorry layer
l plus one
and in the previous layer it will be
layer l so this is a completely
different hyperbolic space
with a different curvature that we um
but we can
use the exponential and logarithmic map
to map the
aggregated results back to the uh
the hyperbolic points in the new
inviting space in the new invest space
with a different curvature
um so the uh formula for all these
computations are very complex
um and understanding them requires like
a
entire lecture on differential geometry
so i won't go very much into the detail
but there are some high level concepts
that you can get from
get get from here so for example in the
message computation because
hyperbolic space has no natural neural
network operations that can be defined
here
we can use this um um linear and
so linear layer basic the linear and
addition
of the bias term uh in the tangent space
of um
of the um of the hyperbolic space
so here we use this um circle and
multiply
uh to represent this like multiply all
the linear linear operation and this
circle and and plus in inside it
to represent the addition so the mobius
addition um
and and these are very um and as you can
see these are
defined through this exponential
logarithmic map here so we first use the
logarithmic map
to map the point the hyperbolic point to
the euclidean
tangent space on that point on the
origin so
here this o means origin so we first map
it to the
um the tangent space of the origin we
perform this
matrix multiplication in the tangent
space and because tangent space is
euclidean
this operation is well defined and after
we perform this linear operation
we can then map it back to to the um
to the hyperbolic space through this
exponential map so
compared to the euclidean operation
basically it has this exponential and
logarithmic map
to convert to and from the tangent space
to perform this operation
and similar is also true for addition
but
here we we need to have a special
operator called parallel transfer
transport which which tells you how to
move the vector around
in the space so this might not seem very
intuitive because in euclidean space
a vector can be moved around the
euclidean space without
affecting its length but actually in
hyperbolic space you cannot freely move
the
vector because as you can see in the
visualization
if we move the if we move a vector
out towards the edge of it it will seem
smaller right the coordinates will
um the the norm of that vector will have
to change so there's this also
the parallel transport here um
and that represents the analogy of the
addition operation in the hydroponic
space
and all this notice that all these
functions although they are very complex
are differentiable so we can also use
pytorch
and any different auto differentiation
software to perform these operations
and in the aggregation this is basically
very similar to graph attention networks
that we have learned
so we have this attention uh weights
here and
we also map it map the points into the
tangent space
uh use the attention waves to aggregate
them and then again
map it back to the hyperbolic space and
in the
update function it again follows the
same uh same
rule where we map it to the tangent
space we perform the non-linearity
but note that here we are map it back to
a different curvature
because the next level has a different
curvature and different space definition
uh so finally just to show a little bit
of results um
here we can see a gnn embedding of a
tree-like structure
and as you can see because there are
exponentially many uh
points in the space and um the
the geometry is not very nicely
preserved
because here we visualize the nodes as
like the lighter blue
nose represent the leaves and the dark
blue notes represent the
root and you can see that some of these
leaves are actually very embedded very
close to the root
which does not respect the tree
structure whereas in the hyperbolic
geometry
using hyperbolic gcn were able to
recover this tree like structure very
nicely and
all the points are embedded in in their
respective hierarchy
and we also discovered that curvature is
very important and there is a sweet spot
where we can impact the
tree with a low distortion but also very
stable numerically very stable
and finally we also evaluated in
a bunch of other other standard data
sets
graph data sets and we basically use
this hyperbolicity to measure
like how good is the hyperbolic gnn
will perform in a given data set so this
metric can be found in this uh chrome of
hyperbolicity paper and basically the
lower
hyperbolicity the graph becomes more
tree-like so here
for example delta equals to zero that
means that the graph is
kind of a perfect tree whereas here if
delta is 11 then the graph is not very
hierarchical or not very tree-like
so we can see that the hyperbolic genome
will
tend to perform very well or extremely
well when hyperbolicity is low
so which means that the graph is very
tree-like whereas if the graph
does not look like a tree then the um
the performance tends to drop so that's
why the hyperbolic genome
is especially suitable for hierarchical
and tree-like graphs
just to summarize here we introduced the
hyperbolic geometry
and we have two models the punctual ball
and hyperbolic mode
model to visualize and represent the
hyperbolic
space in the euclidean as a subspace of
the euclidean space
and we can use exponential logarithmic
map to map points
to and from the tangent space which is
euclidean where neural network
operations can be performed
and finally we show that we we can use a
learnable
curvature at every layer of the gnn
so that we can trade off performance and
stability
um thank you and that's that's all for
this part of the content
you